richtige patient herr gernot zwei plätze
schlechter links funktion rechts
eingeschränkt
und wenn er die stimmung für alle
fokussiert sind und ruhig werden dann
merkt man so okay jetzt in dem moment wo
wir von unserem üblichen plan abweichen
müssen
und nochmal schocken bitte ich habe eine
lange zeit dafür braucht um damit
klarzukommen dass jetzt jemand anderes
prämie tun ist ich versuche irgendwie
das wohlbefinden zu steigern und das ist
das was man sieht und klar das ist das
was man möchte dafür ist mein arzt
geworden
[Musik]
hey ich wills routine ich bin wie viel
studenten und mache jetzt meine familie
am deutschen herzzentrum in berlin
also bei mir sieht ein normaler
arbeitsalltag aus dass ich um sieben
ungefähr umgezogen hier bin
dann werden die fälle von der nacht
durchgesprochen und das war's jetzt
aktuell an dem tag auch ansteht denke
ich immer ein sal
also es war ein patient der mittleres
alter ungefähr war der hat schlechte
arteriellen gefäße dann also der das
herz ist ja ein muskel und es gab
anteile schon des muskels die nicht mehr
kontrolliert haben also gezuckt haben
meinen der stelle keinen sommer stoffen
hingekommen ist also richtige patient er
gern o2 besser aufbauen
schlechte links funktionen rechts
eingeschränkt eventuell beating hart an
der maschine eventuell im teller 55 über
die rechte accessoires
wenn ich mir das jetzt selbst das sagen
wir überlegen als student ist das
natürlich immer schön wenn man im op
dann aber es mitbekommt aber natürlich
auch schön auch mal was machen zu dürfen
das ist ja üblicherweise haut nähte und
so weiter aber eben auch assistenzen bei
operationen und das ist jetzt für
verkleben die möglichkeit mal weil im
einfachen teil der operation als
sogenannter erster assistenz sozusagen
die aufgaben zu übernehmen und ich kann
mich selbst dran erinnern das war schon
mal ein bisschen aufregend
es gibt meistens eine stelle die iss zu
und wir bauen die brücke von einem
großen gefäß also das war jetzt die
brustwand at liebe genommen haben und
brauchen die brücke über die sind
verschluss hinweg und dann kann mit ein
bisschen glück kann das herz dann auch
wieder vernünftig schlagen dann bitte
immer den verein mit der rechten hand
und mit der pinzette die aber das ist
eben der schwebe das alles mal
anzufassen zu fühlen und auch dieses
herz was das für eine kraft hat das ist
es ist unglaublich
einen wunderschönen guten morgen sechs
uhr morgens sind minus vier grad nicht
meine uhr ist nicht meine temperatur
nichtsdestotrotz frühdienst und jetzt
geht's los
ich hatte schon als kind den plan
medizin zu studieren
ich wollte eigentlich rechtsmedizinerin
werden hatte irgendwie den eindruck dass
ich eben nicht mit lebenden menschen
arbeiten möchte dass ich nicht so viel
kontakt haben möchte und habe dann aber
im laufe meines erwachsenwerdens
festgestellt dass das nicht stimmt dass
ich im gegenteil sehr viele menschen
kontakt brauche wir gehen jetzt einmal
zu herrn tietz zur besiegten heute noch
nicht gesehen der hat eine
herztransplantation bekommen und ist
jetzt so weit dass er in die
rehabilitation gehen kann ist immer noch
einmal schauen wie es ihm geht
die gc
danke so wie jetzt geht zum beispiel das
tool keine schmerzen beim schlucken
keine bauchschmerzen teilte porsche
wasser kann endlich der knoten kate
mussten trotz einer erkältung nicht die
größten also hier ist der brustkorb
geöffnet worden
wenn man sich dazu überlegt man wird
aufgemacht von hinten hier hoch denn wer
ein programm rausgenommen der terz
lebenswichtig ist
das wirkt auf einmal ganz anders wenn
man sich mal vorstellen
[Musik]
ich habe eine lange lange zeit dafür ihr
braucht um damit klarzukommen dass jetzt
jemand anderes baby drin ist mich
antreibt ist einfach zusehen dass ich
was getan habe das ist dem patienten
besser geht ob das jetzt egal in welche
richtung das ist ich versuche irgendwie
das wohlbefinden zu steigern und das ist
das was man sieht und klar das ist das
was man möchte dafür ist mein arzt
geworden
da ist
am anfang war alles mit dem ball kann
man erzählt ein bisschen und wenn er
damit die stimmung alle fokussiert sind
und ruhig werden dann merkt man so okay
jetzt in dem moment wo wir von unserem
üblichen plan abweichen müssen
das ist dann schon dieses bahngleise und
da braucht man einfach die komplette
konzentration
[Musik]
ja
und nochmal schocken bitte das herz ist
ja auch umgeben mit einem elektrischen
kreislauf man das ganz einfach sagt und
wenn der mal irgendwie störanfällig wird
durch manipulation oder so weil wir
haben das herz wer bewegt bei ihm hat es
angefangen zu flimmern und in dem moment
jetzt mit ganz kurzen schock also ein
elektroschock dazwischen zwischen diese
reizleitung und dann schlägt das
meistens wieder normal weiter und das
hat es bei mir auch die entscheidenden
sachen sind passiert natürlich alles
wichtig aber das wofür man den operateur
braucht ist erledigt jetzt sich die haut
ist es sozusagen die letzte schicht das
was patienten am ende überhaupt sehen
von der operation
das ist denn die haut und die letzten
letztlich alles ist ein lern für mich
und alle das für mich auch ein absoluter
gewinnen gerade weil das sind eindrücke
die kriege ich im studium nicht deswegen
ich schätze jeden tag der sein kann das
klingt jetzt ein bisschen abgedroschen
und wie eine werbekampagne
aber mir macht es wirklich spaß
[Musik]
ich habe gehört die großen runden haben
sie heute schon erledigt echo ist
gelaufen röntgen waren sie auch schon
sehr schön ich will sie nur noch
ambulant und zur nachkontrolle hier
seien produkte richten will
danke sagen hier war ich habe nur alle
gut unterstützt und hat findet findet
ermöglicht das sieht wieder draußen
teilnehmen
hoch in den spender und dankeschön für
alle gut dass es angemessen nach ihrer
stars monaten doch mal raus
[Musik]
letzten endes haben wir irgendwie seit
ich weiß garnicht drei monaten oder so
sehe ich ihn fast jeden tag kannten ja
auch schon vor der transplantation
das ist dann schön wenn diesen abschluss
hat die werden auch an dem tag da sind
in den ersten tagen dabei und dann auch
am letzten tag das zur sache die mich
freude sie ist mein highlight des tages
heute
hallo hallo ich wollte sie noch einmal
besuchen kommen ich bin froh und ich
finde medizinstudentin ich war bei ihrer
op mit dabei und wie ich zu natürlich
nicht glücklich aber ich find's super
also sie sehen gut aus wie fühlen sie
sich
ja haben sie noch schmerzen und zum
großen teil davon hier liegt kann nicht
oft genug sagen wie toll die betreuung
ist also schön und die nase vorn da tut
die noch wenig ist der kann ja schön ich
habe früher damit dass wir selber
lederarbeiten gemacht ja ja und das ist
eine perfekte lederjacke als dank war
das ist auch ein extremer kontrast man
sieht diesen integrierten narkotisiert
man selbst viele fachwörter aber der
mensch ja einfach im op liegt und sich
nicht bewegt und den wir halt operieren
und dann kommt ja auch station und dann
wird der wach und erzählt auf einmal um
kriegt eine rosige hautfarbe
und ist irgendwie wieder da und
interagiert mit einem und es irgendwie
ein komplett anderer mensch so ein
bisschen
also kommt so richtig so freut man sich
wie schön das ergebnis dann von der
operation geworden ist
[Musik]
unsere neue serie herz und viren ist
auch der zdf mediathek jetzt zu sehen
ihr bekommt unter anderem einen einblick
von corona station der charité und ihr
könnt mich begleiten bei einer
herzoperation im deutschen herzzentrum
berlin schaltet gerne eine ich würde
mich freuen
[Musik]